Speaker 1: Let's speak to a few more people.
We take calls via discord on Fridays at
David Pakman dot com slash discord. That's the
place to do it. Let's go to Harry from Columbus,
Ohio. Harry, what's going on there?
Speaker 3: Hey. Hear me? Well.
Speaker 1: I can hear you. Let's put it that way.
Speaker 3: Okay. I'll be very brief. I'm very
excited for your new finance channel. I saw you
drop your first video yesterday. We now have.
Speaker 1: More of the bold multiple videos on the
Finance Channel. The audience is responding sort
of mildly, positively, which I think is as good
as you can hope for on the Internet, you know?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I agree. So I'll be
real quick. Okay. Now, I know very,
very little about, you know, buying a house,
securing my assets, anything like that. Yep.
With the recent raises and interest rates
from the Fed, does it make any sense to buy
a house until those come down? Like, I have no
idea what calculations I need to make before.
Speaker 1: Well, here is the general.
Speaker 3: Give me a tiny bit of
advice. Yeah, that's it. Thank you so much.
Speaker 1: Here's the general thing. Okay.
As a general rule and we have a clip coming out
on the Finance Channel about this when interest
rates go up. Home prices come down. They tend to
move in opposite directions. Now, it's not always
literally true. Sometimes interest rates going
up. Might just mean home prices are steady instead
of going down. But the idea is interest rates and
prices move in opposite directions. And I explain
why in a clip on the Finance Channel, which will
be out very soon. So if you were in a position.
To buy a home. Cash. High interest rate
environments can be good moments to do that. Now,
of course, if you're selling and buying, often
you're you're subject to the the same market
conditions that make buying attractive might
make you have to sell your house for less. So
it really depends on the market and your personal
situation and whether you're only looking to buy
or buying and selling. But the principle at play
is in general, interest rates up, houses down.
Speaker 3: Yeah. It seems like I'm going to
have to make a pretty, you know, big finances,
a pretty big mortgage change to get into a
house. So it doesn't seem like it's gonna be
the right time for me. I just want to.
Speaker 1: If you have a if you have a
mortgage at two and a half percent right
now and in the new place, you would need a
mortgage at 5%. It may not be the right time
for you. That's perfectly reasonable. Hello.
Okay. Thank you for the call. Very much
appreciate it. Mortgage rates, complicated
stuff. Complicated stuff which we absolutely
will be dealing with on the Finance Channel